the point of making this film is for the
K subo tach and at first uh uh my
friends here students will do what they
consider to be the Kos subo tach and I'm
not going to ask them how to do it what
way they set up they'll just do it
however they feel best to do it the
speed they want to do it and the way
they want to do it and to some of you it
may seem a very boring film because
we're going to go into the finest of
details I normally on a demonstration go
straight into the uh it's more like the
partner practice where I don't slide
back or I don't step forward lower the K
it's because I'm connected and it's more
than just connected if you actually look
at somebody what I do apart from the
visual contact I actually get a a sense
ation inside it's almost like I've
connected with some people might say
their soul somebody might say they're
Aura but but it's a connection that you
know that you've plugged into them so so
I don't need the whole long uh scenario
of the movement but we're going to go
through the whole scenario uh through
the stages in these uh in this film and
we're going to talk about feelings
thoughts and uh and reasons why you
would do what you do there's no point in
just doing things if they don't make
sense uh the Kim subo attach is the
massui part is tying together so I've
told you how I tie together by just
looking at somebody making the
connection I'm tired if I lose that
connection then I've lost my
xan okay so uh well we'll see how it
goes